actually it wasn't even on camera it was
before
I came on camera but there was like a
soft padded bit of this door the rest of
the door is metal and I missed the pad a
bit and I broke my hand and I carried on
into the scene white as a ghost
[Music]
wanted
[Music]
Wesley was a lot of funny play getting
to play a real sort of normal Joe a
normal guy uh whatever normal means and
then you put upon him in extraordinary
situation and people like Angelina Jolie
teaching you how to bend bullets around
dead cadavers of grannies and Morgan
Freeman like just being amazing and
getting to share the screen with him it
was incredible I helped develop that
move and we were trying to figure out
what would it be like in and I was like
well maybe it's like tennis when you're
doing like a kind of I don't know what
that movie I don't play tennis but you
know that move in tennis I mean I also
learned in gun training that I am the
worst shot in the world
and I nearly passed out on that job just
to do the scene where my veins were
popping at my head where they were going
to augment it with CGI veins anyway
what is this [ __ ] is this prick
some losers
the studio didn't outright reject me for
that as I seem to remember and Studio
please forgive me if I'm remembering
this differently or if I have different
information I wasn't outright rejected
it just took a lot of
worrying them in camera testing because
I think teamer or director who was
fantastic and a lovely guy he wanted me
and he was convinced I was the right guy
but this studio just needed a little bit
of help
to convince them that I was the right
guy I ended up camera testing a scene
that ended up not being in the movie
where
the point where Fox played by Angelina
Jolie meets me for the first time
basically does they come with me if you
want to live moment and you know rocks
my whole world and transforms me into a
super assassin that moment in the movie
as it is I'm standing there I think
looking at medication in the the
medication aisle in the camera tests we
went different and I'm actually trying
to commit suicide and I was like
swallowing hundreds of pills in the
aisle as she was like hey your wrestling
Gibson come with me if you want to live
and I'm like oh and uh so I had like 200
Tic Tacs in my mouth for the camera test
how do you know yeah good
that was a great piece of improvisation
from Coleman and Angelina I was like
standing trying to figure out if the
dummy that I'm shooting I start to
realize I think that it's this isn't a
dummy this could be a real person I
think it's a dead person hanging there
that I'm going to be sure
foreign
I think they were asked to sort of
improvise a little bit of this just
background Mumble I don't know if it's
in the film
but she broke you just went hey have you
seen them you've seen Alan or whatever
lately and he goes like nah I think he
broke his leg he jumped off a building
or something and it was just so mundane
and real for what these like super
assassins must be doing for what these
super assassins must go through in their
daily lives the trials and tribulations
of being a stupid assassin and it was so
real and so just like office chat that
it made me lose my [ __ ] and and we had
to cancel the take
X-Men
one day the government is going to
realize how lucky they were to have
Professor X on their side yeah
I suppose I'm a real professionality
next thing you know I'll be going bold
we're still on the government side
tomorrow
still G-Man just without the gene
well
your own team now
it's better
you're
X-Men
yeah
so I like the sound of that so back in
2010 I've been off work for about a year
because my first boy had been born and
um and just decided to stay at home
anyway X-Men came in with first class
and they were filming in Pinewood 40
minutes from my front door and it was
potential to be a like a franchise and I
loved X-Men from a young age loved the
cartoon and also loved Patrick Stewart
primarily from Star Trek from Dune where
he played uh he played Gurnee Hallock I
think and and then laterally from X-Men
itself so that was a massive draw for me
too then also known the work of the
director I thought it was going to be a
very different direction from what
they've done before as much as I've been
a fan of the X-Men franchise I was also
ready for something different and he
took us in a very different direction
intro chromium
a gentleman would at least offer to buy
me a drink first
Newman played a bit for me and a brandy
for the lady please
how did you know that lucky you guys my
name's Xavier Charles Xavier how do you
do so I went and read the script I had
to sit in a restaurant it was I think it
was a Vapiano on Portland Street maybe
and I ran at a time I didn't even get it
finished to be honest with you because
they gave me like a two hour slot and
I'm so slow at reading scripts because
I'm always sitting there taking notes
while I'm reading them I didn't even get
it completely finished but I knew I
wanted to do it I knew there was tons of
possibilities loads of fun potential fun
for me you have with the character and
to take him not in a different direction
because ultimately you'd want to take
him in the same direction as Patrick but
there was an opportunity to show a very
different side of Professor X and
Charles Xavier before he became the
professor to make it interesting to show
he was a different person to begin with
you know Charles Xavier do you have a
minute for a pretty little Beam with the
mutated mcr1 Gene I have five
I say mcr1 you would say Urban Hair
it's a mutation it's a very groovy
mutation mutation right took us from
single-celled organisms to the dominant
form you know what this routine may go
over great with the coeds but I'm here
on business
in preparation for
X-Men Days of Future Past I thought well
I better shave my hair this time because
this is this is it now in prep for that
I got it buzz cut and kind of just very
close it says and got a jar ahead I
thought we'll shave it for you when I
get there when I got to set they were
like no no no no I was like all right I
get script and it's also set in the 70s
and I was like right we're doing hair
extensions and I'll get i'll get real
70s here because they were like oh we
could make this work and I was like no
you really can't make this work and
is going on here
Professor please don't call me that well
you know this guy yeah he looks slightly
familiar get off the bloody chandelier
thanks
you can walk you're a perceptive one I
thought Eric which makes you slightly
perplexing that you managed to miss our
sign on the way in this is private
property my friend I'm gonna have to ask
Kim to ask you to leave then I found out
that Patrick was going to be in the
movie and look how Patrick does as
playing Professor X I wanted to go what
I want to have long hair and I want to
look like I smoke a lot of weed and
maybe do a little bit of something
stronger in the 70s and set in my purple
haze just to show how far that journey
is going to have to be to make him into
Patrick's sure so I said to the main
hair guy I was like do you think it's
possible that we can get somebody in
like tonight who can do head extensions
on me and I had so little hair at this
point so we found somebody and we did an
18 hour head extension session in one
sitting actually I think they came back
for about five hours the next day and I
just sat there for 18 hours going out in
my mind but by the end of it I looked
like Professor X and and Days of Future
Past being on the cover of his hands
getting a medal from the president
you'd like it don't you
supposed to being hunted and despised
well you know actually I do it's all
just a means to an end Raven what end is
that keeping us safe
you should understand better than anyone
that were only ever one bad day away
from them starting to see us as the
enemy again so what we wear matching
costumes and smile and pictures I pay
for keeping the Peace by risking our
people to save their yes yes
I did want to inject a massive ego into
Charles because I think one of the
defining aspects of what Patrick did and
who Charles ultimately becomes is his
selflessness but we'd seen that in four
movies and no more with Logan as well in
the ones that Patrick did so I was like
what are you going to do we want to just
do that again we've got the opportunity
to go back in time and show that he had
to grow into that person so ego was a
massive thing because his selflessness
was so strong in the other movies his
selfishness or his self-centered nature
and it's probably what happens to dark
Phoenix if it was my arc and it was
going to carry on and on and on it's
what happened to Jean Gray that makes
him turn the corner and become the
Professor X that you saw portrayed in
the movie back in 2000.
the greatest gift we have
to Bear their pain without breaking
and it's born from
the most human bar
hope
please
[Music]
Charles we need you to Hope again
first class is probably my favorite
movie but in terms of what I got to do
as an actor I'd say this Future Past was
probably the most challenging the most
interesting experience I had as an actor
on on the X-Men movies but yeah that was
a great bunch of people were still
relatively in contact and hanging out a
little bit maybe on Thursday which is
really nice even though those movies are
behind us now
split glass
M Night Shyamalan in 2015 at Comic-Con
party and we were all there with the
X-Men crew we all got on very well and
we all knew out of a good time so we
were probably partying quite large and
at that moment we had been playing this
really ridiculous game which involved
hitting each other I won't tell you how
because I don't want to have it repeated
and then be blamed for it anyway one of
us got knocked out and it was just after
that that he went hey you ever thought
about uh working with me he then called
up because I think they had somebody
pull out at the last minute and um and
was like listen I'm going to send you
the script I don't want to tell you
anything about it your agent isn't
allowed to read it and you need to sign
an NDA and all that kind of stuff and I
was like okay and within like five pages
I was very excited and just praying that
it didn't get bad because you know like
when you get a good script
and it takes you through page to paste
to page and then maybe around like page
60 just falls apart just like please
sustain please sustain next page is
great please sustain please sustain and
it was great all the way through so
fantastic and I saw what a great acting
opportunity and challenge it was for me
and that's kind of what I'm always
looking for with the character beyond
the greater Narrative of the story what
is the internal conflict what is the
internal challenge or challenges or
conflicts and certainly Kevin and the
rest of the people that share his body
they were massively challenged and
Incredibly conflicted and and curves and
yeah you see that one it's kind of like
a Chenille sweater dress
foreign
who are you
Barry
I don't think you are
probably my favorite character to
portray was who we thought Barry was
Barry was actually Dennis the whole time
it was Dennis pretending to be Barry so
that was like many levels of complexity
that made it quite interesting to play
so you were playing a version of a
young flamboyant designer of fashion
who's homosexual as this British Big Lot
would think he would behave Hedwig was
not quite in control of his body so
there was a lot more loose movements and
things like that I mean I'm not even
quite sure I'm doing the Hedwig right
just now because I can't really remember
what I did specifically but it was more
erratic and it was more frightening
almost because it was coming out of
nowhere
[Music]
foreign
the dance that we had to do for Hedwig
was one of my favorite things that I've
ever had to do on film which was we kind
of we kind of workshopped it a little
bit Knight and I and then we also
improvised some bits but it was real fun
there's a whole bit in it where I get
short and I'm like pretending the blood
coming at me and stuff uh if you wonder
what that dance move is don't worry
I'll talk to him
he listens to me
well Patricia was somebody who I think
had big breasts but she felt quite
modest about it so she was always trying
to put her shoulders forward and have
her her head slightly down and I can't
remember with the rest of them I mean in
the in this the trickle I guess I do
like 20 characters and I definitely
can't remember all of those but those
are the main ones that I remember more
than anything
getting to work with Bruce who had been
watching since I was a really little kid
in Moonlighting that was amazing what a
nice guy what a good guy and really sad
to hear that he's had to retire and I
hope he's well and healthy and hope his
family are all good Anya from day one it
was really clear she has incredible
screen presence and she's just got an
amazing ability to be open to the camera
into the audience which I think is one
of the most important things you need as
a performer get to work with Sam man the
guy is a legend the man who can say
[ __ ] and make it sound like
poetry he was somebody who he went out
of his way
to support what I was doing and that was
a massive Pat in the back for me is a
younger performer who admires him very
very much he didn't need to do that and
he was stunning and also his performance
is just excellent so when somebody's
that good it brings you up as well night
is incredibly specific with this
direction and for that reason the film
that is in his mind is exactly the film
he shoots on the day when it's a
different writer you then meet the
director and who knows the director
might have a different vision from
what's on the page but when the director
has written it you kind of know what's
in his heart and what's in his soul and
what's in his mind and the kind of art
he wants to create and the film he made
is exactly the film he had in his mind
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no problem
on split I broke my hand I was meant to
punch this door I was actually it wasn't
even on camera it was before
I came on camera but there was like a
soft padded bit of this door and I took
to like just punch that a couple times
before I went in the scene because I was
meant to come in like
full of Thriller bins and full of
adrenaline
the rest of the door is metal and I
missed the pad a bit and I broke my hand
and I carried on and at the same white
as a ghost and in kind of shock and
night came up to me I think after that
tick and he was like you okay would that
seem as weird that tape was weird I was
like yeah ma'am let's just go again I
don't think I told him I broke my hand
at that point I didn't realize that I
had broken my hand I don't think but it
became quite clear within a few hours
when my hand was like the size of a
boxing glove and it's actually a bit in
the film where Dennis puts on his
glasses and it's a profile shot and you
can see my hand is swollen up and there
was a parent that I've not seen this but
I've Been Told By Night that there was
people sort of commenting online going
like oh this is he's turning into the
Beast he's turning into the Beast it was
just me with my big Gammy punched up
hand but yeah I kept going and I just
thought it's fine it will probably heal
itself and then on my last day in
Philadelphia before I flew home I
thought I better go to the doctor so I
went to an urgent care and the X-ray
didn't they're like oh yeah you've
broken two Knuckles and I was like oh
God I had to phone up the director of my
next film and say listen would it be
okay if my character was wearing a
plaster cast for the film and luckily it
works for the character and I wore a
plaster cast in the next movie because
of that thank you very much for watching
me talk about my characters that they
said were iconic uh thank you take care